In this lecture. I'm gonna talk about our
first approach to modeling people. And
this is known as the rational actor model.
Now the rational actor model assumes that
people are, well, rational. We make
optimal choices. And it comes under a lot
of criticism, increasingly so, because
people are dissatisfied with some of the
results it produces. Nevertheless, I'm
gonna argue this is a really useful way to
think about people as, especially when
you're constructing models. So what I'm
gonna do in this lecture is define, I'm
gonna describe how it works. I'm gonna
describe the rational actor model first in
the context of decisions, and then I'll do
it in the context of games, which are
strategic interactions where my choice
depends on your choice. After I do that
I'll talk about, you know, give an example
where. Sort of breaks down. Let's talk
about sort of why I think the [inaudible]
is a really useful thing to have in your
pocket. [inaudible] a useful way to
analyze situations. Okay? So let's get
started. So how does the [inaudible] work?
Well what you do is assume that people
have some sort of objective. That
objective could be you know anyone of a
variety of things, but there is some goal
or purpose that somebody has, or group
has, or firm has. Given that objective we
assume that you make optimal choices, that
you optimize. Again strong assumption, but
that what the approach assumes. There is
an objective and [inaudible]. So how does
that work? Well let?s suppose it's a firm.
If you?re a firm you might want to
maximize profits. Or he might wanna
maximize profit share, market share I'm
sorry right. Or, he might wanna maximize
total revenue, those are all things that a
firm might wanna do. If that?s your
objective. What we assume in the rational
reactor model is that you do that, you
make the choice that maximizes that goal.
Now, if your person you might care about
maximizing your own utility. Making
yourself as happy as possible. Or if
you're altruistic, you might not care not
only about yourself, but other people.
Getting the presumption though, is that
whatever your objective is. That you make
optimal choices, to satisfy that
objective. To do as well, as you can
possibly do. If you're a political
candidate, right. What you might do is you
make [inaudible] as getting many votes as
possible. So that's your goal. That's your
objective function. Get votes, and
[inaudible] assumes that you take the
action. Make the choice, to get you as
many votes as possible. Okay. So where can
you apply this? Where can you apply the
rationale [inaudible]? Well, let's take
the simple case of a firm. And what they
wanna do is they wanna you know maximize
let's say revenue instead of profits. And
suppose that their revenue, we can write
it as this way where it gets price times
the quantity. That's how much revenue
we're gonna get. And let's suppose if we
let the quantity be Q that the price will
be 50 minus Q. Now why would this make
sense? Well, if the Q is ten and if I only
produce ten of these things then there's
not many to go around and maybe I can
charge $40 a piece for them. Right? But,
so the price would equal 40. But if I
produce more of these, if I produce
twenty, then there's more to go around,
and that's gonna cause the price to fall,
and the price to fall to 30. So in this
first case, I'd get a revenue of 400. In
the second case, I'd get a revenue of 600.
So the question is, what cue do I choose
to maximize my total revenue? And if you
think of this, my total revenue is Q.
Times 50 minus Q. So the optimal thing to
do is going to be, to have those two
numbers be equal. So [inaudible] equals
25. So I get 25 times 25. Which is 625. So
my optimal choice is q equals 25. So the
rational actor model would assume is, the
firm wants to maximize revenue. That's the
objective function. And then given that,
he wants to choose a quantity that will do
so, so he chooses q equals 25. So where
can you apply this? You can apply this
just about anywhere. So you can think
about, if I'm making investment decisions,
I get some objective and that may be to
maximize the value of my portfolio, or to
give me some sort of nest egg to retire
on. And so I'm gonna make choices that
maximize that. I want to think of my
purchases, right. Or your purchases. Like,
when you go to the grocery store, or
you're thinking about buying furniture for
your house. You could assume you've got
some objective function. And you make
choices, right. That are optimal. Given
that objective. Even if like education
level, you'd say how many years of school
should I get, take, right. Should I just
get a bachelor's degree? Should I get a
master's? Should I get a PhD? Well, you
could assume like, you've got some
objective function which could be you
maybe care about income, you may care
about what sort of life you lead. Is it
life of the mind, is it physical labor?
And you choose how much education to get
given your objective. Now you can even
apply this [inaudible] to how do I vote?
Right, cuz my objective could be for, you
know, some policies to be implemented. So
if I look at the candidates and figure out
which candidate is likely to vote, you
know, implement policies that I want. Now
you also probably wanna figure out is that
candidate likely to win. I don't wanna
vote for someone that espouses my
preferences but has no chance of winning.
So, what I do is choose the candidate who
is likely to win, or most likely to win,
and also takes the positions like the
positions that I prefer. Here's an issue
though that I want to bring up, when we
assume rationality. Rationality, people
often think that means selfish. That's not
true. So let me give you an example.
Suppose I'm walking down the street and I
find a $100. Well, and I'm walking with a
friend, so there's me. And there's my
friend. So one possibility's I can just
say, you know what. This is so cool. I
just found $100.00. I can put it in my
pocket, and give my friend nothing. That
would be rational, if my objective
function was just me. If I could
[inaudible] about myself. But. It could be
this is a really good friend and I care a
lot about my friend. And so when I found
100 bucks, I say hey wait, whoa this is
great, I just found 100 bucks. So I walk
into the nearest store and say can you
give me two 50s. And I give one of the 50s
to my friend because I care a lot about my
friend. So there's nothing intrinsic about
the rationality assumption that assumes
selfishness. So again, selfishness
[inaudible] my objective function is me.
This is how we put it in the framework.
All I care about is me, my happiness, my
income, my wealth, right. Altruistic
preferences would be that my objective is
that I care about other people as well. So
I care about, not only about the happiness
of myself, but I care about the happiness
of others. And I can do all this same
mathematics, right. So here's an example
just like the price quantity example
involving an altruistic person. So suppose
I've got someone that's got an income of
$40,000 and they've got to decide how much
they consume and how much do they donate.
And their objective function is just the
square root. Of their consumption times
the square root of their donations. And
they want to think about how much do I
donate, and how much do I consume if this
is my goal? Well this is just a
mathematical problem, right? So, my
donation is $40,000 minus whatever I
consume. So this is just the square root
of C. Times the square root of 40 minus C.
I can bring everything under the square
root sum. And get the square root of C
times 40 minus C. Where now looking at it
this way realize I wanna make C times 40
minus C as big as possible and the way I
do that is gonna chose C equals twenty so
that D equals twenty. So the optimal thing
to do here is to consume twenty and donate
twenty to split my income halfway between
consumption and donation. That's rational.
It's also incredibly altruistic. I could
be irrational altruistic and possibly
consume less or more than this, right? And
I could also be irrational and selfish.
But the point is that rationality. Right.
This in no way assumes selfishness. You
can be rational and altruistic, you can be
irrational and altruistic. Now, I wanna
move on to something that's sort of
complicated. That is, I wanna make a
distinction between this decision and a
game. So the previous example, that was a
decision. I had to decide how much to
consume, how much to donate. And a
decision, my payoff, what I get, only
depends on what I do. In a game, my pay
off depends on what other people do. This
is where it gets tricky. Cuz for me to
decide what I'm gonna do in a game,
depends on what I think the other person's
gonna do. So therefore I need a model of
what I think the other person's gonna do.
And oftentimes a really good model to have
is to assume the other person is rational.
And that's a lot of how game theory works.
A lot of game theory assumes the other
person is rational and that allows you to
figure out what you're gonna do. So here's
an example. Let's suppose there's two
people. Let's call these people person
one. In person too, and this is what's
called a normal form game. And this is a
game path. I'll explain this in a second.
So person one can decide whether to stay
home or go into the city on a Saturday, as
can person two. If person one stays home
and person two stays home, person one gets
a payoff of one. If person one stays home
and person two goes to the city, person
one still gets a payoff of one. So person
one, if they stay home, their payoff is
one. It's also if they go to the city,
person one's payoff is just two. So one if
they stay home, two if they go to the
city. Person two is a more complicated
person. [laugh], person two, if they stay
home, their path is also one. But if they
go to the city, their pay off depends on
what person one does. So if person two
goes to the city, and person one stays
home, person two gets a payoff of zero.
Because person two is lonely. It's no fun
to go to the city alone, at least for
person two. But if person two goes to the
city, and person one goes to the city,
person two gets path of four. Look at
person two's choice here. This is hard.
Person two is trying to say do I go home,
do I stay home or go to the city. Well, if
person one is going to stay home then I
should stay home because one is bigger
than zero. But if person one goes to the
city then I should go to the city because
four is bigger than one. So it would be
really fun to go to the city. Person two
thinks it would be great to go to the city
with my friend. So, for person two to
figure out what to do, person two has to
know what person one is going to do.
Here's where an assumption of rationality
is really useful, cuz if person one says,
I have no idea what person, person two
says, I have no idea what person one is
going to do. I'm clueless. Then person two
can't figure out what to do. But if person
two says, I think person one is rational,
then person two would say, well look, hmm,
if person one is rational, if they go to
the city, they get a payoff of two, if
they stay home, they get a payoff of one,
so I bet they're going to go to the city.
So therefore, person two thinks person 1's
rational, person two thinks person 1's
going to the city, therefore person two
goes to the city, and they get this great
payoff. Okay so that's where when you
think about decisions you have to make in
the real world you often have to have some
model of what other people do, and often
times a decent model is to assume the
other person is rational, right, that
they're going to do the rational thing.
Let's do another example. That was an
example of what we call a normal form
game. This is an extinction, extensive
form game. Now an extensive form game,
these are sometimes called game trees, and
you sort of draw the action, action
sequentially. So here is, is a green
person, right, and a blue person. So the
green person's gonna go first and they're
gonna say "Do I go this way? And if I do,
we both get payoffs of zero, we're going
to move down here. If we move down here
the blue person gets to move." So the
green person's gotta decide hmmm. What do
I think the blue person's gonna do? Well,
the green person passes it down to the
blue person and he looks and says the blue
person can move over here, and the blue
person will get two and I'll get two.
Where the blue person can go straight
down, and the blue person will get three,
and I'll get minus three. So if the green
person assumes the blue person is
rational, the green person is gonna say,
well look, three is bigger than two.
Right. And so the blue person's going to
move down here. Well then, the green
person is going to say, well even though I
could get two, two, I'm not going to get
minus three, so I'm going to move over
here. So again here by the green person
making a rationality assumption on the
part of the blue person the green person
can figure out what to do. Okay, so when
would we see rationality? Rationality
seems like a strong assumption. First case
is when the stakes are really large. So if
you think about it, like, if you're just
in, you know, buying lunch somewhere,
maybe you just follow some rule of thumb.
Right, or if you?re trying to decide you
know exactly how many bagels to buy at the
bagel store, you know maybe you just sort
of pick a dozen or something. But if you
think about buying a house or buying a car
or deciding where to go to college or
deciding whether to go to college, those
are large stake decisions and in those
situations it?s probably the case that you
come fairly close to being rational. 'Kay,
when else? When it's repeated. So there's
been a lot of experiments on whether or
not people are rational, what we often
find is the first time somebody does
something, especially like, remember that
mounty hall problem with the three tours
we did? First time people do stuff they
typically, they often don't get it right,
right? But the more and more you do it,
people tend to learn and we get closer and
closer, right? To being optimal. Third
case. When you have groups of people
making decisions. Now groups can get led
astray and you can get groupthink and
terrible choices and escalation of biases
and that sort of thing. But, typically if
you bring in more people, you're less
likely to make an irrational decision.
That's why, when we're making large-stake
choices, right [laugh], we often go and
ask friends and family and other people
who respect, so that we're not making
these decisions alone, so there's some
sort of group of us making the decisions.
And then last case is, I mean, one reason
we make [inaudible] choices is [inaudible]
choices are easy to make. And if someday
says would you rather have $twenty or
$ten, we'd choose twenty. If someone says
would you rather do less work or more
work, we'd typically say I prefer to do
less work. So why then if rationality is
often too complicated and why if we just
think about people don't do ration, act
rationally, why make the assumption? So my
advisor, one of my advisors was Roger
Miason who won a Nobel Prize in the theory
of mechan, called mechanism design, which
is a, sort of a branch of game theory, in
a way. And Roger makes this. Follow a
compelling argument. That rational
behavior is an incredibly important
benchmark, it's probably the most
important benchmark is you think about
modeling people, why?  Well, first off, it's
unique. Most of the time, not always,
but most of the time it's gonna be unique.
So think about that case of the firm
deciding how much quantity to produce to
maximize revenue. Or think of the person
trying to decide how much to donate to
charity. There's a unique answer, so it
gives you this. Definitely testable
amount, [inaudible] say this is what
rational behavior is. Okay, second thing
something that's easy to solve for. So
even though [inaudible] is hard and
practice. We're writing all these
mathematical equations okay, so we've got
this function that looks like this. It's
often very easy to use mathematics to find
the actual point. To find, you know within
the [inaudible] model. What someone should
do. So let's contrast this with Irrational
behaviors. Suppose I write down some model
and say, people are irrational. Well, I've
got two problems. One is its not unique.
Right? There could be 1,000 ways to be
irrational. So I have no real prediction
coming from the model. The second thing
is, it may be really hard to figure out.
What exactly is it that this person's
gonna do in this context if I start taking
in all these sort of psychological
influences and contextual influences and
that sort of stuff? It's often just easier
to say, here's their objective function,
let's just assume they optimize. Another
point, another reason it's an incredibly
important benchmark. People learn, and we
talked about these experiments that over
time people get things right. Well, if
over time you're moving towards the
rationality assumption then maybe the
rationality assumption's sort of not a bad
place to sorta start, and then you can
sorta say this is where we expect the
system to go over time. Right? And then
last. In can be the case that, even if
people make mistakes, if there's no bias
on way one way or the other in terms of
the mistakes, those mistakes my darn well
cancel out. And what you're left with,
then, is something that looks pretty close
to rational behavior. So some people could
spend too much, some people would spend
too middle, little. And therefore, on
average, you get something that looks
close to rational. Okay, so what have we
seen? What we've seen is this is that
rational behavior. Works from the
following set of assumptions, you assume
there's some sort of objective function.
And then you assume people optimize, given
that objective. This could be firms, this
could be people, whatever you want it to
be. Now, strong assumption yes, but a
really powerful benchmark. Now one of the
things we found, from doing a lot of
experiments we , Psychologists,
Economists, all sorts of people,
Scientist. What we found is, there are
places where people sort of systematically
deviate from rationality. That's what
we're going to look at next, we're gonna
get some specific biases where the
rationality assumption, sort of seams
consistently not to hold. Now there's
going to be cases where it does hold
[inaudible] where it consistently doesn't
hold. Nevertheless, it still can be useful
even if you think it's not consistently
going to hold. To think through your
model, assuming rational behavior to get
that sort of benchmark, to see what would
rational people do. That way when you're
actually looking at the evidence. You can
see exactly how far from rational people
how we are behaving. Okay, thank you.